Wendy Williams ditches her signature
dresses play black string bikini on the
beach how you do it
[Music]
ahead of her new season premiere the
talk show host is soaking up her last
few days of summer vacation yes a
wonderful summer by soaking up the Sun
in Bermuda isn't that fabulous
the 53 year old star kicked up the waves
in this teeny black string bikini which
perfectly showed off her ample assets
and impossibly tiny waist my lost 50
pounds and I've kept it off for about
two years now it's nice not having the
feeling of oh my gosh does this angle
make me look fat you know no really
that's what you go through and I'm I'm
not a thin woman but I didn't tell you
I'm the best physically than I've ever
been in my life and it makes me feel
very confident to just get out there I'm
not worried about the clothes
Wendy also went for a dip in the
crystal-clear blue ocean it's still
sporting her signature W necklace a
bright pink lip pendants and matching
shades describe her style to me just in
a couple of words fun flirty and fitted
[Music]